in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Chris
is with us hey Chris how are you hey how
are you better than I deserve
before you from I live in Nashville ah
neighbors then right here just right
across the street
very cool good so you're here to do your
debt-free scream I am
travel the whole 20 minutes I know it's
terrible how much debt have you paid off
ten thousand dollars and some change and
how long did that take you six months
good deal making what kind of range of
income during that time well I started
my first year as a teacher and amazing
salary of $36,000 gotcha
okay cool what grade do you teach I
teach band mill school band
good for you which go laverne middle
school Oh Nate very good well there's a
little more than 20 minutes then yeah
for more area anyway okay good well good
to have you so six months ago you got
the new job you got out of school is
that what started this process well the
the journey actually started about two
years ago when I was student teaching
friend of mine my roommate actually I
was telling me about this guy that he
found podcasting I just would yell at
people on the air and just tell him if
they're doing dumb things with their
money and got me hooked on it
so then fast forward yeah fast forward
to last June I
well started my first year as a teacher
was getting ready to and I started
looking at the numbers of my student
loans and it was kind of freaking out
you know looking at the salary that I
was going to be making and then you know
the amount of debt I was thing alright
this is gonna take me you know two years
I did the math I'm a math person so I
did then I did the math there's two
years to get all this stuff paid off and
then about that time our church offered
FPU so I went through that with my
girlfriend Rebecca and we went through
the class and I just a little fire in me
and six months after that it was all
paid off you landed on just like that
and then we coordinated the next class
so I mean you have been on beans and
rice when you have had night rice can of
beans you have had no life I mean you
because you're your take-home pays
I mean I don't know how you did that
this is tight it's not really I was
looking at it today the math just
doesn't really work its I'm gods in
there somewhere yeah he's got to be in
there stir in the pot literally that's
awesome man
very very cool well I'm glad you did it
I'm glad you did it so fast because now
you're free right and it's and now
you've proved now you've proven to
yourself you can conquer the the money
Monster at a young age with an with not
much income yet and you know you can do
anything now you got a thing in front of
you so what are you 25 23 23 okay very
cool very very cool 10,000 bucks paid
off in six months now you're
coordinating a class yep
Wow good for you so when someone says aw
you can't get out of that you tell them
what did you do to get out of debt you
have to be intentional with everything
they're doing I mean from your money to
your lifestyle you have to be
intentional and that intentionality
leads you to do what I mean what what's
a technique for you getting out of debt
that you think's the most important
things you you actually did I mean one
would you cut lifestyle yeah really your
sacrifices you cut it deep I mean
friends my age were going to concerts
out to eat doing the whole thing and
just you have to say no and make those
sacrifices give up six months a
lifestyle
six months to get it done hard and fast
yeah nothing but what I still use the
spaghetti
what else did you do well just there
wasn't really a debt snowball because
there's just a debt right
and it's well I'll tell you something
that didn't happen and being a musician
you have the opportunity to play shows
for money or you know kind of outsource
yourself and teach different places and
about the time I decided I want to start
paying the debt off and get it done
quick the phone started ringing and you
know not a whole lot but that extra cash
but you guys kept out yeah I got some
gigs and it it really did come in handy
what do you play what's your primary I'm
percussionist ah there you go just like
that good deal all right well done very
well done all right Chris from Nashville
23 years old brand-new teacher making
thirty six thousand ten thousand dollars
paid off in six months count it down
let's hear your debt free
screen right three-two-one
ah well done star very well done
love it excellent man you can do
anything if you can do that absolutely
powerful stuff well done
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show and say you have to break the
cycle you have to flip this thing on its
head and make it behave you've got to
get so fired up and wired up that you're
broke friends think you've lost your
mind